welcome to CBS this morning as you wake
up in the West we are breaking news for
you on the corona virus outbreak you
were looking right now at the Costa
Smeralda that's an Italian cruise ship
docked just north of Rome around 6,000
passengers 114 of them Americans are now
being held on board this morning because
of fears that a passenger from China has
coronavirus Italian media reported a
short time ago that preliminary tests
found no signs of the potentially deadly
illness but samples are being sent for
further testing Carter Evans is at an
Air Reserve Base near Los Angeles where
nearly 200 Americans who were evacuated
from Wuhan the epicenter of the deadly
outbreak landed yesterday Carter what do
we know about possible coronavirus
patients on that ship the passenger in
question arrived in Italy from Hong Kong
last weekend boarded the Costa Smeralda
now health officials are trying to
determine if the 54 year old woman has
the flu or the corona virus video
obtained by CBS News from on more the
Costa Smeralda shows passengers
patiently waiting for results on whether
a fellow traveler has been infected with
the deadly coronavirus
health officials say a Chinese National
Law Board came down with a fever and
started experiencing breathing problems
before docking back in Italy the ship
visited one port in France in two in
Spain it's not clear whether health
officials are concerned about the
transmission of the virus their
passenger Mike Luigi it's pretty normal
on board I mean we can just move around
we don't have to stay in our cabin to
celebrate the Lunar New Year millions of
Chinese nationals are travelling
throughout the globe Luigi estimates
that one in seven passengers on the
cruise ship come from China I'm not
stressed on I don't see any person
stressed just like okay we wait and see
what happens
the communication is goods back in
Southern California a group of nearly
200 evacuees from China are being
monitored for the disease did you have
any high-risk individuals on the flight
there were no individuals that responded
to the questions indicating that they
were high risk
we're reassessing that now the CDC's
reassessment includes nasal swabs and
blood tests but some Americans were left
behind at Wuhan and remain fearful they
got through several of the screenings
got their tickets got through the
medical check and then James Dickies
ex-wife and eight-year-old daughter were
told they were bound for the US on the
only flight out of Wuhan but because his
daughter didn't have her passport they
were denied entry at the last minute I
just felt so defeated at that point and
it sort of felt like both countries had
let me down how's the father supposed to
feel when his daughters in harm's way
the Red Cross is standing by in case any
cruise ship passengers need to be
transferred to the hospital meanwhile
the World Health Organization is meeting
to try to determine if this should be
considered a global health emergency is
concern and Carter thank you very much